so in the real world of sales
understanding how to down sell like a
champ
is one of the reasons that you'll be
able to massively increase your pro your
close rate
what's going on everyone welcome back uh
quick uh little tactical training for
you today as well
um how to close everyone down selling
like a prop so one of the big beliefs
that i like to set in our community is
that everyone
buys something what i mean by that is
that everyone has some money
right no matter what and everyone has
this problem and we should find a way to
help everyone to a certain degree
right and obviously you want to try and
sell your primary program because that's
going to be your objective that's
because you think it's the thing that's
going to help them the most
et cetera but there come times where
people can't afford it for whatever
reason right this is reality all right
anyone tells you otherwise
whatever so in the real world of sales
understanding how to down sell like a
champ is one of the reasons that you'll
be able to massively increase your pro
your close rate now doing it properly is
one of the key
is one of the key points here all right
so when you do it poorly it sounds like
begging and it sounds like you totally
lose your frame uh in the sale and now
you sound desperate and aggressive
and clingy and you sound like you've got
i love this term commission breath
and and basically just ruins the sale
and then they don't even if they could
afford it they don't want to buy from me
because of what you're doing right it
sounds unethical etc like wait you just
said it was this price you're just going
to keep lowering it
and so the key to doing this is having a
key set of cards that you have in your
back pocket
that you can choose to play as you go
down
right so it's kind of like a step down
all right and the way that you do this
is through exchange
all right so one of the other powerful
influences in human psychology and jet
in general is is reciprocity all right
we have a very hard time
uh if someone gives you something not
giving something back
the beautiful thing is is that after you
exchange something
the person who sets the terms always has
the power in the agreement so for
example
um if someone asks me to do something
which is essentially what they're doing
when they say no they can't afford that
they're asking you
to do something for them right can you
do it for less that's that's the
implication right they can't do it for
that what else can you do
and so uh there's a study that like
showed this and i mean there's hundreds
of studies that show this but
where they took people in colleges and
they let them
uh cut in line and the thing is
is that doing a small favor people don't
have a good idea of what
of what it get like equality in an
exchange
and so if you do a small favor for
someone and after you do the small favor
then make a big ask it's still very hard
for people
to say no all right and so that's the
things that people don't have
with reciprocity uh an idea of fairness
of exchange there all right like it's
like
hey yeah i remember i bought you lunch
yesterday uh can you take me to the
airport and back this weekend or can you
help me move out of my apartment
like that's not a fair exchange but the
thing is is that with reciprocity people
will say yes to things
because of just underlying human
psychology all right
so here's how you use reciprocity which
is one of the strongest things
motivators for persuasion
in a down selling environment all right
so after let's say you offer your your
primary program you're like hey
it's you know it's x right and they're
like
i i just can't afford that so he says
this you say
tell you what i'll do it for this
if you xyz right if you leave me a
testimonial
so i'll drop the price in half if you
leave me a testimonial
fair enough and when you say that it's
like they asked you to make a a
some sort of adjustment you take that in
consideration you make the adjustment
and you make the offer again and you say
does that sound fair
right and the thing is is it's very
difficult for people to keep hearing
that
over and over again and not say yes so
i'll give you an example one of the step
downs that we use that's really
successful
and so let's say we're selling a front
end program for 300
all right for 300 bucks a week very
straightforward three weeks all right
so they say no they say you know that's
too much for me to say
no problem what if we just did 49 weeks
for 12 weeks
right with a commitment and so we're
doing is that you always have these you
always have these cards that you can
play so in a fitness example
right you have the term so how long
they're committing to that's number one
number two you can ask them to give you
a testimonial you can ask them to give
you reviews
you can ask them to bring a friend and
each of these things
are things that you can ask them to do
so that you can ethically lower the
price because you're asking them to do
more
all right on top of that you can also
add bonuses in the original package
i don't like removing bonuses as much
because like i want to give them those
things
um and so it's more like i'll i'd rather
go in the other direction of asking them
to do more things for me
um and that way if someone else is like
why is she paying x and i'm paying z
you can say well she's doing some extra
things for me that you're not
and they're like oh and so that way
you're not saying like
two people are having different prices
for the same program because you've made
additional terms to the agreement right
so traditional stepdad would be like hey
can you do this thing for 299. they say
no you say awesome
no worries uh you know what i can just
cut the price in half and if you can
just commit to 12 weeks fair enough
they say no and you say okay no worries
let's just not even worry about the
commitment just get you started today
for 49 bucks fair enough
they say no you say all right and you
have to acknowledge that it gets kind of
increasingly ridiculous as you make more
and more offers right in it
in a light tone because it's still going
to pull on that internal mechanism
inside of people
uh to take action and say yes okay so we
started we've already done two drop
downs we did
half price with commitment then we
removed commitment 49
all right we're 49 and we eliminate
commitment that's two step downs
all right step underneath that you're
like all right how about this i'll do it
for 39 if you leave me a testimonial at
the end fair enough
and also when you have the testimonial
you're also putting another implication
that they're going to get results so
you're selling while you're
while you're down selling at the same
time right now you've said
three down cells fair enough they're
like no i still can't do it
you're like all right cool let's just
get you kicked off at 29 a week
pay as you go don't worry about it uh
and just
bring a friend in the first 30 days all
right that way i can at least cover my
costs and that way it gets me to at
least
half price what i was saying before fair
enough it's hard for someone
to hear that make have you make all of
these
uh what is it accommodations for them
and not say yes three four five six
times and
be very clear about how you're asking
for this don't just say
sound good sound great cool that's not
the call to action the call to action
when you're down selling i mean i really
like this in general what i'm selling
is fair enough sound fair
because you're lowering the bar to just
say yeah that sounds fair
you're like awesome great what card you
want to use let's get you started right
if you want you can even transition
really cool do you want to do your uh
you know nutrition appointment
in the morning or the afternoon so
you're already taking more micro steps
in the right commitment before you ask
the card if you want to do that
all right but i'll go i'll go through
this one more time for everyone who's
listening
so primary offer it's 2.99 it's got all
this amazing stuff
uh fair enough no okay no worries
um what we can do is if the price is uh
enough but you really still want this if
you if you want to just go longer which
you're probably gonna need anyways right
um i'll do it for 49 a week which is
half of what i said earlier
all right fair enough and when you're
asking this you have to ask it like you
actually want them to say yes
and that's why the tonality is so
important don't just like read the
script and be like sound fair
like you have to be like fair enough
like you have to really
you have to ask it like you're actually
asking them to say yes
i know this sounds minor but it's
everything over the phone when you don't
have your body
to make so that they can see because
only nine percent of communication is
verbal right
and everything else is how you say the
words not just the words you're saying
right i can give you another example of
like how i can take one sentence and
make it mean like six things by how you
say it all right
sales the same thing so big program they
say no
commitment at half price fair enough
they say no you say listen don't worry
about it i get it sometimes
it can be scary how about this i'll just
let you get started for day
pays you go i'll prove myself all right
we don't have to get married we can just
start first date right
uh 49 all right fair enough
you got to really wait for it and
they're like ah you're like okay
you're killing me here that's okay no
worries we'll get this started all right
we'll figure this out together the thing
is is that when you're doing this it's
collaborative
you're you're on the same side of the
table saying let's figure out a way to
make this work
right because if you have built the
rapport throughout the sale you've dug
the pain
right so they know that this is
something that they need to do and they
know they need to do it with you
they will work with you as long as
you've maintained rapport and you don't
get aggressive
right and so you're like okay no worries
how about this
i'll do it for 39 a week all right so
it's 25 off of my already 50
off right uh if you just leave me a
testimonial at the end fair enough
it's hard for like it's hard for people
to keep saying no to that and you're
like
okay 39 all right
i'll do all right this is this is the
this is the best i can do all right
because at this point i'm pretty much
paying you to work out
all right so it's i can do this for 29
all right
just send me a friend in the first 30
days that way at least um i can get back
to the 49 that that just at least covers
my costs
fair enough we say it like that you see
how the tonality changes
right they're like man this guy's really
trying to help me out he's really trying
to accommodate me and so when you drop
down that many
like at this point we're at six drop
downs okay so
so this person all right um if they say
no at this point then in my opinion it's
not a money thing you lost them earlier
on in the sale and they're trying to get
off and at some point earlier on they
became disengaged with the phone call
right that's where you get the hey can i
get the credit card they hang up
right it's because they're just done
with the conversation they just want
they just want to get off the phone
right in person
they can't just get off the phone you
have a little bit more fighting room
over the phone it's not that way right
and so these are the things
and that's why you have to confront the
obstacles earlier on like someone's
disengaged
uh they're not paying attention they're
giving you surface level problems
that's really like hey can i be real
with you instead of nice to you
and then you deliver the deliver the
pain like hey i'm not saying that to
make you feel bad all right i'm saying
that so i can help
right and so when you say that it's like
you've you've you've given yourself
permission to inject the truth
rub the pain a little bit but then you
you put a band-aid on it afterwards all
right
and so anyway that's that's that's early
on objections i won't get into that
right now
um but knowing how to down sell will
massively increase your crows rate
and by adding these little cards that
you have that you can trade with people
on
allows you to have flexibility in the
deal right and then that way
they can feel like you accommodated them
you still help them and then ultimately
what you're doing is just trying to get
your foot in the door because in seven
days and 14 days they're finally going
to trust you and then they'll buy the
full
the full price program later like don't
worry about it it's just like
let's get you going let's get you in the
in our world so that we can provide
value and then after that
we'll make it work all right so uh two
cents on down selling
you need to know how to downsell and you
know how to do it ethically without
sounding like you're begging or being
pushy
and that's how you do it all right lots
of everyone if you like this drop a
comment drop a review drop
you know drop a whatever engage with
this um
and uh have a have a miraculous
wednesday all right catch you soon bye
[Music]